BEMENT TELLS US
BEMENT TELLS U
DEPARTMENT SAYS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS FUNDS TO
FIGHT THE INTERFERENCE IN U.S.
ELECTIONS.
>> SECRETARY OF STATE TILLERSON
ACKNOWLEDGED HIS DEPARTMENT MUST
BETTER RESIST THE CAMPAIGN.
THEY ASSIGNED THE GLOBAL
ENGAGEMENT CENTER THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF RESPONSE TO
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
IT SECURED 50 MILLION OF THE
DEDICATED FUNDING.
>> BUREAUCRACIES CAN BE SLOW,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE
UNDERSTAFFED LIKE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND D.O.D. AND
ACTUALLY MOVING THINGS ALONG,
EVEN IF THEY HAVE BEEN MANDATED
BY CONGRESS.
>> NOW IT HAS THE 40 MILLION
ENGAGEMENT CENTER IS ASSIGNING
THE MONEY TO PROJECTS AND HAS
USED OTHER FUNDING TO COUNTER
MISINFORMATION.
BOB MENENDEZ OF THE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE SAID THEY
NEED TO PLAY CATCH UP QUICKLY
AND PUT THE FUNDS TO USE TO
DEFLECT RUSSIA'S DISINFORMATION
PROGRAM.
NONE OF THEM SPEAK RUSSIAN.
ANOTHER SOURCE FAMILIAR WITH THE
CENTER STAFF SAYS IT DOES EMPLOY
RUSSIAN SPEAKERS, EVEN IF THE
CENTER BECOMES OPERATIONAL.
>> WE DON'T HAVE A NATIONAL
RESPONSE STRATEGY.
WITH THIS KIND OF THREAT TAKES
IS REALLY A WHOLE OF SOCIETY CH
IS REALLY A WHOLE OF SOCIETY C
APPROACH.
>> INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS SAY
THE UNITED STATES IS STILL